two things firstly a lot of you have
decided to email me no wait a lot of you
did not email me in a fit of rage
enlightening me to the fact that I must
be the world's biggest for not
giving even more of a discount on
bitwixe to do too so for those of you
who did not email me while foaming at
the mouth and seething thank you for the
rest of you who decide to let me know
that you were utterly shocked and
appalled that I would do such a thing is
not given even bigger discount on
bitwixe to do - as much as I hate to do
it I did go and figure it out and I have
brought back 15% off bitwixe to do -
this does not work on the upgrade don't
rage out on me I don't have control over
that stop this only works for new
purchases so 15% off for life okay
because even if you are the world's most
magnificent douche I want you to have
bit wick and I'm doing that for bit wick
and myself not for you but yeah 15% off
now this is how you get it you have to
click the link in the description you
have to click that link okay and then it
brings you to the bit wig page and then
you type in offer cold alex bond and but
I being 15% off bit weak studio - and
that works also for the asked video
tutorials that they sell in there I
think they're like 20 bucks and they're
pretty good second of all I tried to
find an answer to the age-old question
that every man who comes of age my ass
themself is can you create an entire
song and bit wig studio using only one
MIDI track and well we're gonna take a
look at that in just a second and number
three because there is a number three I
apologize there hasn't been many video
uploads lately I've been busy been
working I've been sick and and frankly I
haven't had that time to do it so videos
coming back up soon but I mean the music
industry in Canada is starting to ramp
up because the snow is finally melting
despite our recent ice storm but I will
still put in the time and effort to
provide some kind of content at the end
of this video maybe I'll show you some
clips of what I've been up to okay back
to the age-old question can you make an
entire song just using one MIDI track
and bit wig studio - and the answer is
yes well no not really I mean kind of
but it depends solely on your definition
of a song alright let's just jump in a
bit wig studio - and I'll show you what
I'm talking about
[Music]
all right let's see what I've done here
okay so like I said we're gonna make a
song using just one MIDI track this is
the MIDI track I called it King because
it rules them all I didn't want to call
it master cuz we already have a master
and that's just gonna be weird so let's
just have a listen to what this thing
sounds like
yeah anyone else did anyone else fall
asleep during that cuz as I did for sure
so basically this is just the guide
track this is just playing out the notes
I've muted it it's not really doing
anything this is basically like having
someone sit in the corner and play this
exact pattern on their keyboard for me
without stopping until I tell them to
stop okay okay so now you can take other
tracks like this are pissed wack and
then real simply to grab those notes you
just need a note receiver if you want to
make more out of those notes you throw a
multi node in there if you want to make
sure they don't stray away from the a
minor pattern that you've played in you
throw a diatonic Transposer in there
throw an E minor and and then if you
want to play those notes independently
make a little melody you throw an
arpeggiator in there and then for this
instrument I'm using the phase four I'm
using a preset called are pissed thwack
and and basically I just left it alone
and then to bring it in and out of the
song I've just done a bunch of
automations like this for example and
you know turning the arpeggiator on and
off things like that okay muting the
source if I don't want to hear it
whatsoever and and so that's pretty cool
so let's just have a listen here
just realizing now one thing I should
have done is thrown a high-pass filter
on their due but it did do a high-pass
filter
and I've been at it and just put it down
that like 100 not even like 200 there we
go
let's have a listen
[Music]
yeah okay I just didn't want those low
notes in there interfering with my bass
okay so and then I lined up another
basically one of these see I put this
this thing here I put it into a chain I
got smart now it's all in a chain so
basically I have my note receiver
diatonic transpose and our Peggy ater
inside a chain and then I can just drag
this to all the other tracks as needed
and and I can fill it with them from
there but instead of me loading these up
on every single track that would be
tedious and and you're also probably
wondering why there's actually MIDI
tracks on here but they're empty yes
they are empty MIDI tracks the only
reason I'm doing that is so I can take
chunks of this like all the automation
and everything comes with it so I can
take chunks of this and copy it over and
it copies all the automation that I've
done with the the MIDI clip and same
with all the rest that's the only reason
there is some so let's have a listen to
this I think this doesn't start til so
yeah basically you know like nothing's
changed here I've got my chain in front
I've chosen a poly synth patch that
wasn't the button let's see there's the
button called cyborg shanty and and I've
just done some things I put a ladder
filter there and I automated the filter
see you can see like that and and I've
put a tool device with an audio side
chain that is side chained to the drums
over here and and that's basically it
like no more no more than that that was
like a three-minute setup for this guy
okay and let's see close that up and
then same with the bigger bass let's see
some automation here yeah same deal you
know there's my chain I didn't need an
arpeggiator I did want to make sure it
was in a minor and it's a poly synth
with a bass patch let's see what's it
called bigger bass and and a filter and
basically that's it this is a high or a
low pass filter just making sure I'm
only
the lows because it's quite an
aggressive bass sound let's check it out
[Music]
pretty weird pretty weak on its own here
we go we have my sub bass that I've made
in previous videos and these are two
serum patches again I just have my chain
and I have my pitch shifter because I
need to you know transpose everything
down a couple octaves and then I have
serum distortion this is all this was
all a preset that I had created way long
ago in a previous video something to do
with sub bass you didn't check that it
if you want and then I've automated
let's see filter cut-offs and stuff like
that just you know yeah so nothing
nothing crazy okay drums you can't you
can't really follow that MIDI pattern
with drums like you just have to on you
have to straight up make drums so here I
have my auto hats which is basically I
made this in another video too if you
want to figure out how to make this this
thing is my favorite tool that I've ever
created and basically you just create
one MIDI note where is it
one MIDI note for as long as you want
high hats and then and then you have
these little buttons here to change the
pattern so let's just have a quick
listen to what that sounds like
yeah so you know what I mean like if you
if you had to go and draw in all those
MIDI notes you'd your brain stem would
leak for sure by the time we got to the
end of the song so don't do that just go
to watch that video called Auto hats or
high hats the easy way or something like
that and and you'll see here we go is
another it's not really a preset that I
well it is a preset so it's just a drum
kit and I've put in you know some
interesting sounds and then I saved it
called the AV a noise kit and and that's
basically it's some filter automation
there and it's just playing a basic
pattern yeah nothing nothing exciting it
just you know does that and then by the
time you do all of that you start to
realize that maybe making an entire song
off of one MIDI track is a little bit
tedious and it doesn't really break out
of the norm and and so at this point I
started to color outside the lines and I
added in a serum patch called the voice
of God and I drew in or I played some
chords here just because they just
needed to be there you'll see what I
mean they just that you know it's
necessary I promise you it's necessary
to have those chords when you listen to
the song you'll see what I'm talking
about and well why don't we just do that
now let's listen to the song again
yeah so pretty much though everything is
running off of this MIDI track here and
you could definitely go way harder than
I did this is a very simple track
there's what one two three four five six
seven tracks in total one of them's a
cheat the voice of gods a cheat and the
drums are just two tracks that I drew in
you know nothing nothing crazy but let's
check it
[Music]
[Laughter]
see what I mean not too bad all I'm
saying is in this terrible example is
that you can do quite a lot just by
using the what do you call it the note
receiver diatonic transpose are an
appreciator and and just shifting it
around like instead of writing in all
that MIDI and copying it pasting it all
over the place if you're gonna do it
anyway just use the note receiver for
sure and die and I'm curious like you
guys will definitely go way harder than
I will on this I have very limited time
at this point that's you know the music
industry is ramping up but I'm curious
what you guys come up with any ideas
that you might have definitely throw
them in the comment section so that
everybody else can see and think and
absorb whatever you've come up with okay
and you see what I mean about the voice
of God kind of just had to be in there
didn't it listen
[Music]
you know what I mean all right let's uh
let's get out of this program here
already do you ever find that being in
this program is a lot like Tron like do
you feel like when you're watching my
videos it's like you're trapped inside
of my computer because I kind of feel
like that it's like Tron and then when i
zoom way and like this and we play the
track you know and we have the the
follow thing on it's totally like you're
just you're it's like it's like you're a
two-dimensional Tron
you know what I mean maybe not okay
let's get out of this program for a
second okay so what did you think you
see what I mean it's the answer is kind
of yes but with an asterisk again 15%
off bit which to do to click the link in
the description used off the code Alex
Vaughn also screen capture software if
you want to record your screen and make
videos like this one then and you don't
really want to pay any money well you
have to pay some money but if you don't
really want to pay much money and you
want the software then check the
description down below because I believe
it's 20 there's a 25% off of the movavi
screen capture software so again you
gotta click the link and then use the
offer code
Alex Vaughn and that'll love that'll
dunk a bunch of the money away dunk a
bunch of the money as far as what I've
been up to the same old stuff man just
working a bunch of audio gigs a couple
great bands you should check out one is
called forest and the other is a kid
named Aiden Myers I'll put the links
down in the description so you can check
that out also just enjoying the
beautiful sunny hot spring weather here
in Canada and and staying busy
saying I was the easiest window straight
doc so satisfying and now it's time for
the little YouTube or spiel so I would
forgive you if you left now because
quite frankly I always do at this point
in other people's videos but please hit
the like button hit the subscribe button
if you like to follow me on Instagram
it's just at Alex
oh no it's at Vons place or is it Alex
Vaughn no it's at Vaughn's place VA in
whatever you know what I mean
also I have a patreon page set up if you
like to support what I do here then
you'll find that link down in the
description and also if you want to know
what gear I'm using to make these videos
and these songs you'll find affiliate
links for Amazon down in the description
because you can just never have enough
gear right so that's it done over see
you in the next video okay please don't
rage comment don't rage email me anymore
you're getting your 15% of quick okay
and and just you don't think about it
think about things you know when you
when you message people they're people
I'm a person damn it
okay see you folks ciao